[Musique]
Madeleine blémorin Michel Saugier
Nicolas bonsoir bonsoir
avouez que vous avez souri winter
de Michel cy je vous en je vous voyais
pas je vous entendais sourire
c'est le début de Richard III prochain
je veux commencer ce soir avec le
dossier de l'immigration
nos collègues de la CBC je vous montre
le tableau il y a 60000 dossiers en gros
qui auraient abouti dans des boîtes
vocales en fait dans des sous la
responsabilité d'employer inactifs soit
depuis deux ans trois ans quatre ans
soit la retraite alors vous imaginez
bien que l'employé inactif ne peut pas
répondre d'abord on répond plus aux
demandeurs maintenant c'est des systèmes
plus compliqués
ce qui montre premier tour de table
Madeleine c'est un exemple parmi
d'autres de ce qui pointe vers une
gestion défaillante dans ces gros
systèmes là on le dit du retard du
retard du retard
oui on parle beaucoup de 40 ans de
nikado là c'est jour si moi ça m'a fait
penser à Astérix c'est la maison qui
rend fou les 12 travaux d'Astérix avec
se laisser passer à 38 là essayez
d'obtenir la voie de sortie dans un
système qui est devenu très impersonnel
pour les immigrants donc la journaliste
c'est son deuxième reportage elle en
avait fait un premier il y a quelques
mois elle avait vu dans des groupes de
discussions des demandeurs de
l'immigration qui essayent de naviguer
dans ce système qui disait où est
l'officier des m132 donc des gens qui
réalisaient que leur officier leur agent
ne répondait pas était complètement
inactif et la journaliste en question a
fait la demande pour savoir quelles sont
tous les agents qui sont inactifs dans
le système et d'où ce reportage là le
gouvernement nous dit ah il y a rien à
voir ici inquiétez-vous pas il y a
plusieurs agents qui peuvent travailler
sur le même dossier donc soyez rassurés
mais j'imagine que c'est très très
inquiétant pour des gens qui ignorent
combien de temps ça va prendre et à peu
près un dossier sur deux qui ne
respectent pas les normes de temps à
louer généralement par le gouvernement
fédéral pour ce qui est du ministère de
l'Immigration donc c'est un ministère
qui est lourd c'est un ministère qui est
lent et c'est pas le genre de reportage
qui va rassurer la population à ce sujet
là exactement Michel c'est
le ministère de l'Immigration et
probablement le champion des blancs de
la du vérificateur général année après
année ça fait ça fait très longtemps que
ce ministère là est inefficace et
inefficace pour les étudiants africains
qui veulent venir au Québec on invente
toutes sortes de choses en disant on va
peut-être avoir des chances de rester
mais ils sont inefficaces dans à peu
près tout ce qu'ils font alors c'est pas
très surprenant mais savoir qu'il y a
des dossiers donnés à des gens qui sont
plus là je comprends qu'il y a peut-être
des dossiers qui sont parrainés par deux
ou trois agents là mais un moment donné
ça marche pas et les explications du
gouvernement ne tiennent pas ça fait
trop longtemps que ça dure il faut
vraiment un ménage là-dedans et le
gouvernement jamais l'air prêtre à
vouloir le faire alors imaginez si on
augmente les seins d'immigration à 500
000 par année il a commencé le
cafouillage va devenir important il y a
le ministère des migration du Québec et
pas le plus performant
du gouvernement du Québec et bien
meilleur que le système du gouvernement
fédéral alors un moment donné il faut
prendre le taureau par des cordes puis
régler le
procès
le problème c'est que quand on parlait
par exemple que quelqu'un que moi de la
crise dépasseport
c'est sûr que les personnes
nécessairement qui demandent leur
passeport sont des Canadiens il y avait
une réponse politique très forte à cet
enjeu là le problème de de design disons
c'est que le ministère l'immigration
sert des personnes qui sont pas
citoyennes et qui donc sont en attente
d'avoir un statut ici c'est beaucoup
plus difficile pour les gens qui sont
pris dans cette situation là de
critiquer même pour les journalistes qui
courent sur cette question là il y a
beaucoup de personnes qui refusent de de
témoigner de peur que ça allait une
influence sur la manière dont leur
dossier traité donc on joue
essentiellement avec des vies humaines
qui sont là qui savent pas exactement
combien de temps vont pouvoir être là au
Canada il y en a qui qui sont des
étudiants étrangers qui ont qui ont
diplômé qui cherche à avoir la résidence
permanente avant que le permis travail
temporaire expire ces gens-là sont dans
les limbes essentiellement puis mais
parce que c'est pas des personnes qui
sont citoyennes il a réponse politique
et toujours plus longue donc vous avez
des raisons pour laquelle sa ministère
là il y a des problèmes depuis plusieurs
années moi je le vois autour de moi j'ai
des personnes donc qui sont actuellement
dans ce système là c'est sûr que ça
génère énormément de frustration et il
va falloir que les gens qui sont des
journalistes ou les gens qui sont des
citoyens sans même par solidarité parce
que si c'est seulement aux gens qui sont
dans le système à élever la voix par
l'essence même de leur statut ça va être
très difficile pour eux de faire bouger
des choses qui sont plus fragiles puis
des fois ici d'abord je posais la
question vous allez voir le rapport dans
une seconde à Louise Arbour ancienne
juge en chef au Canada qui a qui a c'est
penché quand l'État à l'ONU beaucoup sur
les la crise migratoire sur la planète
et comment les états devront gérer ça et
je lui demandais le chemin Roxane on
peut pas fermer accent d'abord c'est
notre obligation internationale de les
accueillir mais je veux dire oui mais
attends deux trois ans
pour une réponse quelqu'un qui entre
c'est pas normal et c'est un
contournement de l'immigration légale
elle a dit oui mais le problème c'est
pas qu'ils entrent c'est que ça prenne
deux trois ans à leur répondre c'est la
gestion du ministère je fais entendre ce
petit extrait là et on revient
la gestion le si on tombe là dedans
c'est un gouvernement qui est pas
capable de mettre des passeports à ses
propres citoyens en bas de toi moi ça
m'étonne pas beaucoup
on est dans une bureaucratie à tous les
niveaux au niveau de la gestion des
services de santé la gestion de la
justice des tribunaux on est en espèces
de déficit de performance à tous les
niveaux de service ce qui est assez
étonnant considérant qu'on paye quand
même beaucoup d'impôts on a toute une
population qui est dans une espèce de
clandestinité à cause de déficience qui
sont là très très souvent purement
bureaucratique
on parle souvent du monstre
bureaucratique et c'est vrai du
ministère de la santé au Québec ici
c'est tout ça Immigration Canada en soit
Madeleine c'est un beau col oui pour
rebondir sur ce qui est un instant et
sur ce que Michel disait il y a un
instant il y a quand même un nombre
important d'immigrants qui arrivent leur
année après année on va bientôt
atteindre effectivement un demi-million
c'est le Canada respecte ses cibles et
ce que j'entendais en coulisses c'était
pas tant qu'on craignait au gouvernement
d'avoir un ressac politique là-dessus on
pensait pas qu'il allait avoir par
exemple un parti qui allait contestée ça
mais on se demandait si la machine
allait tenir le coup mais la machine bon
il y a le monstre du ministère de
l'immigration mais on a entendu d'autres
exemples récemment que ce soit le Bureau
du vérificateur général qui se plaignait
du fait que le gouvernement soit pas
plus proactif pour aller chercher de
l'argent qui avait été dépensé entre
autres pendant la pandémie on parlait
aussi de single technologies récemment
c'est cette
contrat qui avait été donné pour des
systèmes anti-espionnage des
communications de la GRC de gouvernement
blâmet la fonction publique donc tout ça
on dirait qu'à chaque fois bon la
fonction publique et là pas capable de
faire son travail mais le gouvernement
est derrière cette fonction publique là
et je voyais qu'il y avait un
commentaire de Donald Savoie qui est à
la tête d'une Chaire de recherche sur
l'administration publique disant il va
falloir avoir une commission d'enquête
nationale sur la fonction publique parce
que ça fonctionne plus comme il faut
c'est pas sexy comme dossier sauf qu'à
un moment donné c'est que tout le monde
qui paye si la fonction publique ne pas
été assez soutenu par le gouvernement ou
si des décisions n'ont pas été prises
après ça c'est touché par le gouverne
paralysé de peur de se tromper de peur
de pas de faire la bonne chose fonction
publique qui peut être paralysée aussi
par un savoir ce produit qui a écrit
le bureau du premier ministre qui était
très très puissant
donc il a écrit toute une série de
d'ouvrages sur la fonction publique
c'est sûr qu'un gouvernement en fin de
mandat va pas nécessairement vouloir se
lancer là-dedans parce que c'est une
certaine façon un aveu d'échec sauf
qu'il va falloir un moment donné
conscientateur très bien
au début du mandat monsieur Trudeau il
faisait des séminaires avec des experts
britanniques sur le mot anglais c'est de
lever de dire la capacité de livrer la
marchandise la réalité c'est ça c'est
que le gouvernement fédéral perd de plus
en plus sa capacité de livrer c'est pas
juste à l'immigration Madeleine a bien
raison c'est ailleurs aussi mais il y a
comme une cassure entre le ministère et
ses fonctionnaires dans beaucoup
beaucoup de ministères puis ça là
effectivement que ça soit une commission
d'enquête ou autre chose il faut réparer
ça rapidement très bien je vais passer à
l'autre sujet passer un test important
pour Monsieur poignet qu'on a vu il est
arrivé Madeleine on était là cet été à
Star Wars est arrivé comme un sur un
cheval
puis on se disait à la table d'analyse
ce soir là Trudeau a devant lui un
batailleur puis chaque bataille va aller
jusqu'au bout ça va être extraordinaire
or dans mes sessions
[Musique]
ce soir c'est comme si disait bon ben ce
que je me trompe Madeleine où il baise
les attentes pour les conservateurs
c'est un circonscription libérale bien
sûr il est bien baisser les attentes il
fait bien de baisser les attentes parce
que là s'il perdait les élections ce
soir ce serait encore une plus grosse
défaite pour lui mais je pense
véritablement que oui c'est un test pour
Pierre pauliev parce que c'est le genre
de circonscription en banlieue de
Toronto qu'il va devoir remporter si
l'espère former le prochain gouvernement
c'est un test à plusieurs mois des
élections donc même s'il ne réussit pas
ce soir ça veut pas dire qu'il va pas
réussir le jour de le soir de l'élection
mais
c'est lui qui a le plus à perdre ce soir
c'est juste un Trudeau si les libéraux
perdent cette circonscription qu'il
détenait depuis 2015 là on verrait
effectivement que Pierre poillière
galope sur son cheval encore plus vite
là puisque c'est le combat Madeleine
rapidement puis je vais passer aux
autres a-t-il véritablement
fait ce combat pour aller remporter je
vais vous montrer un tableau
effectivement monsieur un peu leur
emporter en 2011 sinon c'est libéral
depuis à peu près toujours mais est-ce
que Monsieur poignet est allé sur sur la
scène pour faire le combat pierre
poillievre est allé dans les communautés
culturelles justement dans la banlieue
de Toronto il a participé à plusieurs
événements un peu comme Jason Kelly
Kenny l'avait fait justement en 2011
lorsque les conservateurs avaient
remporté leur seule majorité sous Steven
Harper mais est-ce qu'il a fait
suffisamment de travail mais je pense
qu'on aura peut-être une idée ce soir
les libéraux confiance là j'ai plutôt
l'impression que et si les conservateurs
l'emportent ce soir c'est peut-être là
ou c'est la surprise
Madeleine le dit là c'est une
circonscription bon monsieur un peu
l'avait remporté que les conservateurs
doivent remporter un jour s'ils veulent
de revenir au pouvoir on est il y a
l'inflation trois mandats de Monsieur
Trudeau gouvernement minoritaire est-ce
que c'est pas un contexte où il y aurait
fallu pour Monsieur poignet que ça soit
que ça soit gagné peut-être ce soir
Michel
[Musique]
info
avait été essentiellement mis à la porte
assez cavalièrement
du Parti conservateur comme chef l'un
des l'un des enjeux l'un des métiers
chez qu'il avait fait campagne un peu
plus au centre pour essayer justement
d'aller chercher longtemps et puis
pierre Pauline va faire campagne en
disant nous on va pas essayer de faire
campagne vers le centre on va être très
fidèle aux valeurs conservatrices on va
s'afficher d'une manière bleue disons
foncé puis les gens les gens vont suivre
donc c'est un peu ça la stratégie du que
Pierre Paulien va pris dans les derniers
mois aussi c'est sûr beaucoup en étant
en étant très actif sur les médias
sociaux peut-être plus même que sur le
terrain et certainement beaucoup plus
que dans les médias qui a traditionnels
donc dans un sens je comprends que étant
donné que le comté libéral depuis
longtemps c'est pas autant un test que
si c'était vraiment compliqué pivot ceci
dit ça les résultats ce soir au moins
les chiffres envoyés des signaux sur
est-ce que la stratégie pierre Polia
peut vraiment
comment ça se situe ça situe
essentiellement en Ontario et je pense
que il y a quand même des signaux qui
vont être pris par l'équipe de Pierre
poliev pour se réajuster pour la suite
des choses
et les libéraux un bon candidat c'est un
ancien ministre national alors ouais
alors ça c'est ça joue aussi là
oui mais d'accord
je m'incline devant vos analyses
les amis il faut qu'on montre qu'on est
capable de remporter ça là pas dans 107
ans surtout avec la rhétorique
l'inflation et Machin qu'utilise
monsieur poignet
c'est sûr que s'il a emportait s'ils
avaient cet élan là ce soir ça serait
vraiment un vent dans le dos pour les
conservateurs avant Noël ça
encouragerait les troupes conservatrices
ça serait vraiment un bon coup pour eux
s'il réussissent ça me surprendrait
qu'ils aient pas essayé là ils ont ils
ont placé là un candidat qui correspond
aussi à l'image qu'ils veulent projeter
un policier de la région donc proche de
leur programme de la sécurité publique
proche de la classe moyenne aussi on
verra bien un mot un Madeleine sur
vendredi rencontre entre monsieur
Trudeau monsieur Legault les attentes
sont élevées est-ce qu'on va vraiment là
c'est vraiment une vraie réunion de
travail ce sont vues au Maroc en Tunisie
plutôt là il se revoit pour vrai là oui
en Tunisie c'était en marche du Sommet
de la Francophonie le ton était bon mais
là ils vont se rencontrer pour vrai on
va parler semble-t-il de santé c'est ce
qu'on nous télégraphie du côté du
gouvernement fédéral du REC du français
aussi comment lutter contre le recul du
français est-ce que c'est par la voix de
l'immigration peut-être est-ce que c'est
par la voix de l'immigration en français
hors Québec c'est aussi ce qu'on laisse
entendre le qu'on veut pour une première
fois atteindre les cibles de
l'immigration francophone en Québec très
bien on aura l'occasion d'en reparler
Michel et Émilie merci beaucoup à vous
trois on lance la semaine comme ça merci
merci
pour voir nos émissions en entier
rendez-vous sur la chaîne ici RDI